à partir de 1841 quelques années avant sa mort
Madame de Bassam fit construire une chapelle à
proximité de la maison de maître ce
lieu de culte est destiné aux habitants
des hauts d'échantillon ainsi qu'aux
nombreux esclaves de la propriété
après l'église paroissiale de  Sajan Leo a été
construit en 1856. La chapelle
est restée la propriété de la famille jusqu'en
1969, date à laquelle elle est devenue propriété du diocèse à la
réunion des années 1930. Mgr
Misano da Booma passe régulièrement quelques
moments de silence avec ses descendants.
Le village sur la tombe de Madame de Besson.
ils célèbrent aussi la fête de Saw Michelle
le 29 septembre
ce dessin bâtiment excessivement surélevé
et aiguisé ne résiste pas à la
violence du cyclone qui frappe l'
île le 4 février 1932
les restes du bâtiment ne sont que des
ruines seulement quelques ensembles  des murs de la
Rotonde sont encore debout la chapelle est
reconstruite à l'identique dès 1933
toujours avec quelques modifications notamment
l'ouverture à quatre nervures diagonales
qui en atténuent l'excédent elle est
circulaire avec un tambour octogonal au
sommet et avec un toit haut  sa forme
a donné le nom de Chappell funky Sharp
Chapel l'architecture de style néo-gothique
à laquelle elle est assimilée est due
au travail élégamment maîtrisé des
nervures diagonales depuis les années 1980 après la
première restauration la décoration intérieure a été
réduite à sa plus simple expression  l'
IRA aperçu lointain des
vitraux colorés restants les
reliefs et moulures des lambris
peints en blanc sont soulignés de
bleu l'autel d'origine daté de 1845 est
impressionnant par sa blancheur de marbre
situé dans l'axe du porche il
affiche une croix mention AHA EF  réalisé
par Vital Booski une sculpture de non
[Musique]
pendant plusieurs années après que les derniers
descendants vivant dans la maison principale
aient quitté un habitant du quartier
Augustin piojo également connu sous le nom de ne sais pas
non Anton Ohno était le gardien du
lieu et de la mémoire de  quelques légendes
de tradition orale qui ont fait de
Madame de Besner un personnage populaire et contesté
en 2003 une nouvelle campagne de
restauration permet de restituer dans la
Rotonde un décor peint et des lambris
qui divisaient le mur en 24 jours se terminant
par un arc en arc cette chapelle était
classée monument historique en
1917 et offre à ses visiteurs un
beau témoignage de l'
architecture religieuse insulaire